on this higher
and this
three or four month period in jaguars
history
as being one of the most significant
things
you know ever
because not only do you get
uh
you know a coach that everyone has you
know mike everyone i've talked to
everyone has an asterisk
on urban meyer
okay and that asterisk is that he's quit
jobs at 45 45 46 and 54 years old
and he's never lost and he's about to
lose who knows how much but he's about
to lose
but but you know the whole thing is
you know they
jacksonville jaguar shod khan smart
businessman is going to take the gamble
and so hey it's going to be fascinating
to watch
i would bet you that the jacksonville
jaguars will be a subject
on this
program
five times as much in the next 12 months
as they have been in the last 24 months
because urban meyer is going to be
interesting he's going to bring a lot of
attention to the job he's going to draft
trevor lawrence
and we're going to see
this team
start to take the steps
back to respectability now
is it a good hire we'll find out if he
saban's it
if after two years he's under 500 and he
calls shot khan and said
i can't do this i i ca i just can't do
it i gotta get out then we're gonna say
shot you should have listened to the
warning signs but today it's exciting
it's fun it's good for jacksonville and
i think it's good for the nfl
and that is the big news on this friday
morning the jaguars hiring former ohio
state and florida coach urban meyer
which right there in and of itself the
higher the timing what does it do it
bigfoot's divisional round weekend what
are we talking about we're not talking
about any of the four games right out of
the gates are we we're talking about the
jacksonville jaguars why the hell else
would we have any reason to talk about
the jacksonville jaguars they stink
they've stunk they've stank and now all
of a sudden they've got urban meyer and
you're right whether it works or whether
it doesn't the jaguars are relevant now
they'll be relevant for as long as urban
meyer is there and peter as you were
explaining that i thought of two people
one you mentioned if he sabans at nick
saban two years with the miami dolphins
tormented hated it couldn't wait to get
back to college football because he
couldn't stack the deck with the
equivalent of 10 first-rounders every
year
instead of the one first-rounder that
you get as an nfl head coach because
like nick saban urban meyer excellent
recruiter getting the best players easy
to win a lot of football games when you
have the best players on your team
second name i thought of peter and this
was inspired by an observation you made
in the
days leading up to the 2019 season when
kyler murray was a rookie kyler murray's
never lost kyler murray has another
option in baseball what's colin murray
going to do
if all of a sudden he's lost three games
in a row when he'd lost three games
combined in his high school and college
careers is he going to say i'll fight
through the adversity or is he going to
say screw this i'll go play baseball so
urban meyer same deal is he going to
fight through the adversity or is he
going to say screw this i'll go coach
usc or some other program where i can
stack the deck where i'm not constantly
tormented and torment is the key chris
spielman
had some great comments a couple of
years ago on a podcast when urban meyer
was going through the final throws of
his time with ohio state he was bent
over and is it health issues what is it
and spielman made it clear that it's
very simple you can't let the job
consume you and meyer is letting the
stress of it consume him well if it
consumes you
when your team
is always in the conversation for the
best in the country of a hundred plus
programs
it's going to consume you even faster
when you're struggling just to stay in
third place in the afc south peter
yeah i think the really interesting part
of that right there mike is
okay so if you look at
what happens when you take a head
coaching job
in college football
you have a very finite job to do
okay you have you have assistants who go
recruit for you who report back to you
you might have to go into for the kill
with certain players
okay but at a level of florida and ohio
state
you are not on the on the road for 200
days a year okay
you have to basically manage the program
be brilliant and as an offensive mind he
is really really smart
but in the nfl
i believe
there are so many more things you have
to worry about in addition to the fact
that you've got 31 other franchises
including three in your own division
who are either almost as good as you or
better than you
you know in terms of talent in terms of
resources
and and look at this division now and
let's just assume
that there is peace in our time in
houston
uh after the season and they can smooth
things over
you know with desean watson i don't know
if they can but
the houston texans have one of the best
five quarterbacks in football
and you've got to play them twice a week
uh ryan tannehill he's one of the best
10 quarterbacks in football you've got
to play him twice a year and now
indianapolis i have no doubt that chris
ballard and frank wright will figure out
the quarterback position
whether that is going to be and i doubt
it carson wentz or you go with rivers
one more year or
you know you take the jump and you start
developing a younger quarterback so
nobody is going to be purdue
nobody is going to be uh illinois okay
and and right now that is what i think
everybody is concerned about
about losing and i've heard
from from someone you know who knows
urban meyer very well is that
you know he said he thinks that urban
meyer understands that the difference is
if you lose a second game in college
football your season is over but in the
nfl you could lose a sixth game and your
season is still alive so he's not going
to go as crazy after a loss we'll see if
that's true
but that's what i hear the the sort of
urban meyer ethos entering this job is
going to be
that's definitely the vibe among ohio
state fans they understand you can get
maybe away with one if you get to two
that presumption every year that you're
going to be in the mix for the national
championship goes away and it is a ton
of pressure and look it's more localized
but those ohio state fans are over the
top crazy they're more passionate than
any fan base in the nfl i can guarantee
you of that so maybe there will be
less pressure as crazy as that sounds
even though it will be much harder to
dominate the way that he dominated at
the college level and peter you
mentioned the texans you ran through the
quarterbacks you know a point that
someone made to me yesterday and it was
good enough that i stole it and wrote
about it last night on pft the texans
are now under even more pressure to not
screw up their hire and they're all over
the place hey let's talk to eric b enemy
oh wait we blew the window to talk to
him during the bye week now we have to
wait till the chiefs are done who are
they going to hire are they trying to
placate deshaun watson what's their
vision who's in charge what other
changes are they going to make they'd
better get a good coach in there because
now you got urban meyer frank reich and
mike vrabel in the afc south that the
texans head coach is going to have to
match wits with twice per year so
and as the jaguars
turn into a team to be reckoned with the
texans have to worry about
falling off the map and
the mere fact that urban meyer is with
the jaguars making desean watson more
determined to get the hell out of
houston
i mean we'll see i i
you know i'm one of these who uh
one of the one of these people who
i don't think it's over for deshaun
watson in houston you know i think that
you've got to give the general manager
who just took over this position a week
ago
you've got to give them a little time
you've got three and a half months mike
you don't have to make a decision next
week you don't have to make a decision
next month you don't really have to make
a decision until the day the first day
of the draft which i believe is april
29th
and so
you know i say
just let all of this simmer down the
water is at a boil right now let's wait
till it gets to room temperature
and let's wait till
the texans hire a coach and on february
10th
reach out to deshaun watson and ask if
either at a very respectful distance
social distance
we can get together the three of us and
have a conversation
and maybe bring an owner who uh you know
deshawn probably
has very little use for now
uh
you know because he thinks that that uh
cal mcnair ignored him uh in looking for
a general manager and perhaps a coach
but i i just think that needs to be
soothed we'll see what happens i'm not
saying it's going to get solved i'm not
saying it's not going to but i think to
say with any kind of certainty that
desean watson has played his last snap
for the texans i just think is way
premature
my point though is the texans got to
make a good hire at coach now that
meyer's in the division and that higher
is going to influence don't take
patience
by the way by the way by the way don't
you think now in some ways
that it really
it kind of increases the pressure on the
texans to hire eric b enemy
don't you think so well because
honestly yes
go ahead
yes no i agree with you i mean they've
got to get they've got to get this right
they've got to get things soothed and
their only chance of soothing it with
deshaun watson i think is hiring the guy
that he said go higher
right i agree totally and and look
look
i don't care how it comes about
you know it's like when people say oh my
god so-and-so wasn't a first ballot hall
of famer
i can't name you other than the the
cause celebs like uh tara owens i can't
name i'm on the committee for 30 years i
can't name you oh was he a first ballot
i don't remember
you know you remember the famous ones
because people keep bringing up but it's
just like would anybody ever remember
after eric b enemy uh you know goes to
the super bowl in his fourth year with
houston oh man they they screwed it up
they had to be forced into hiring people
would remember it but it would become an
old story
and in my opinion it doesn't matter how
you get a job it doesn't matter how you
get there when you get the job take
advantage of it and personally
i don't care you know i just i really
very selfishly i'm sorry i want to see
the guy get a chance
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports